combien de temps encore je vais devoir
rester ici j'ai besoin de votre aide
sur vic sentir le feu en moi j'ai envie
d'explorer d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec un garçon qui a une
voiture c'est quoi une voiture arrête de
broyer du noir
regarde ça plus tôt ils cherchent des
auteurs un concours pour devenir
critique de rock
jésuite joanna morgan j'ai un entretien
pour l'annoncer vous avez trouvé qu'on
article été bon quand même c'est pas
vraiment d'autre
paul cherry
des types comme eux ont besoin de fille
comme toi
allez on y va
milieu du ciel c'est le ravisseurs
d'enfant djouhada morrigan est morte
face à vous la légendaire d'hollywood
soir encore à 9h du rock'n'roll ça ne
voulait rien dire pour moi à minuit
c'était devenu la chose la plus
importante au monde
jerry moyes est ce que tu as déjà fait
merveille je n'ai jamais rien payé
double
valence et en voilà mais pour pouvoir
danser et lui remit avec des gens qui
sont communes et et ont tous deux bien
précis
je vous présente le web non mais il
vraiment le problème c'est qu'une fois
qu'on se retrouve du côté obscur de la
force
on ne le voit pas du tout le côté obscur
pas question de jouer la c1 quel moment
tu as pété un câble
et quoi pourtant se construit et qu'on
se rend compte que pour se construire on
n'a pas lâché on déchire tout et on
recommence
[Musique]
ça ça on aimerait publier dans notre
prochain numéro je suis très touché
merci infiniment maintenant et est-ce
que tu joue un rôle là au moment où je
te parle
[Musique]